remember the me to movement how could
you not it was after all one of the
biggest stories to rock 2018 will here
in France it was better known as balance
Tompa essentially that means to call
someone out as acting like a pig and it
really grabbed the media's attention all
great except fast-forward a few months
later and we find out what's really been
going on journalists the publicity of
the communication more linearly you
learn just a Magister Severson more yes
all the time when the moral brigade were
flying the banner from me to a number of
senior journalists in france were
reportedly engaged in coordinated online
harassment mainly of female writers and
feminist activists the lol League macho
online boys club consisted of around 30
members and was founded back in 2009 it
spread explicit memes abuse victims on
social media and doctored photos to
humiliate them suffered from attacks on
Twitter when you tweet something you
have 30 people who come and call you
completely sick I lived in fear there's
always this tension of when will it
happen and in what form so it's very
humiliating and the humiliation double
since is now online and public and
accessible to all I had a morbid fear
that this can turn to real violence it
was not violent online but in my head it
actually turns physical so how did this
hugely embarrassing scandal come to
light well it was accidentally
discovered when one newspaper left-wing
liver hassle carried out a fact-checking
exercise exposing that to of its own
journalists as not being only members
that one of them actually founded the
cyberbullying group several journalists
have now been suspended from a range of
outlets and some have even offered
apologies although not everyone has held
on to the feeling of guilt for very long
to those jumping for joy in their
vengeful bile by saying phew well done
to these idiots now we're going to clear
our own dirty laundry go to hell for ten
years these bullies have been operating
like a pack getting high on power on the
pain they could inflict in reality
they've been exposed as what they really
are
the League of largely obsolete losers
and the lofty liberal media in France
has been left with egg all over its face
Charlotte Dubinsky Otte Paris
you